la sucrerie de pierrefonds dans les
années 1920 1930
l'industrie sucrière réunionnaise
connaît une période de prospérité
les propriétaires en profitent pour
rénover leur usine
priorité est donnée à la technique
parfois au détriment de l'esthétique
sauf à pierrefonds reprenant la
tradition des belles usines
édifié dans le sud de l'île 50 ans plus
tôt léonus bénard construit entièrement
la sucrerie de pierrefonds en accentuant
la mise en scène du bâtiment d'origine
on y pénètre par trois portes en plein
cintre situé en léger retrait de la
façade de part et d'autre des murs
décorés de pilastres soutiennent le
premier étage ce dernier percée de douze
portes fenêtres aux délicates menuiserie
rappelant le décor des grandes maisons
créoles
la vague de fermeture qui touche
l'industrie sucrière réunionnaise à
l'aube des années 1970 n'épargne pas
pierrefonds la sucrerie ferme
définitivement ses portes en 1969 après
seulement quatre décennies de
fonctionnement comme celui de plusieurs
autres usines réunionnaise son matériel
de production est envoyé à madagascar
bien qu'on très mauvais état l'ancienne
usine et les bâtiments qui l'entourent
forme d'un ensemble architectural unique
présentant une grande valeur historique
c'est à ce titre que le terrain
d'assiette de 5 hectares ainsi que la
totalité des bâtiments et ruines ont été
inscrit au titre des monuments
historiques en 1998